during the direct message last week i
mentioned how people from all over the
world watching and listening to the
reuben report are connecting through the
power of ideas immediately after we
posted the video online the comments
section lit up with people chiming in
from around the globe for those of you
keeping score here are the countries I
heard from in no particular order
macedonia hungary poland lebanon denmark
ukraine united kingdom finland United
States Canada Italy Iraq Slovakia Israel
greased I wan Germany Russia Switzerland
Argentina Ireland Belgium Georgia
Netherlands Bangladesh South Africa
India New Zealand Norway Brazil
Australia Portugal Spain and even North
freakin Korea by my count that's 35
countries and that's just from the
people who happen to comment on the
video or tweet to me wherever you are
you are a living breathing example of
why ideas about secular values and free
speech matter for my interviews to you
guys furthering the conversations on
social media where igniting ideas and
people all over the world who share in
the same ideals as the civil rights
activist Medgar Evers said you can kill
a man but you can't kill an idea so
whether you're listening to this in the
comforts of your vacation home on the
Italian coast while on a bus in India or
in an apartment complex in war-torn Iraq
you are a piece of the puzzle of
reclaiming liberalism and having honest
conversations even with those whom we
disagree ideas have brought us together
but I think we're just at the precipice
of what this conversation about free
speech and liberalism could become so
now I want you guys to be part of the
show more than ever before I think we
can do something bigger than just
emailing tweeting and facebooking I want
to talk directly to you consider this my
official request to have you yeah you on
the reuben report we're going to take a
group of five viewers from five
different countries and i will interview
you via skype for 10 minutes posting
them all as one complete episode i want
to know who you are what you do why you
think the conversations we've been
having here are important and how you
came to think the way you do
together I think we can amplify our
message of conversation human rights and
secular values in an exponential way I
don't care if you're religious atheist
Republican Democrat black white gay or
straight what I care about is yeah you
got it your ideas with this in mind
joining me this week are my friend and
former guest feisal Syed Ali Matar and
first-time guest Melissa Chen feisal was
born in Iraq and now lives in New York
where he works with movements org an
organization dedicated to helping people
escape closed societies melissa is from
Singapore got her PhD at MIT and is the
manager of the global secular humanist
movement these are two people who are
using their voices to help those who
need it most and now it's time to make
your voice heard to go to aura TV /
Ruben report or click the link in the
description right down below and let us
know why you want to be on the reuben
report oh and complimenting the host
probably won't hurt your chances
you